♪ I Google you
♪ late at night when I don't
know what to do
♪ [piano playing]
♪ I find photos you've forgotten
you were in
♪ put up by your friends
♪ [piano playing]
♪ I do I Google you
♪ when the day is done
and everything is through
♪ I read your journal that
you kept that month in France
♪ I've watched you dance
♪I've YouTube'd you
♪ And I'm pleased your name
is practically unique
♪ it's only you and a would-be
PhD from Chesapeake
♪ who writes papers
on the structure of the sun
♪ I've read each one
♪ I know that I should let you fade
♪ but there's that box and there's
your name somehow it never makes
♪ the pain grow less or fade or disappear
♪ I think that I should save my soul
and I should crawl back in my hole
♪ But it's too easy just to fold
and type your name again
♪ I fear I Google you
♪ Whenever I'm alone and feeling blue
♪ And each scrap of information
♪ That I gather says you've
found somebody new
♪ [piano playing]
♪ And it really shouldn't matter
ought to blow up my computer
♪ but instead...
♪ I Google you.
♪ [piano playing]
♪ Only the lonely
♪ Know the heartaches I've been through
♪ Know I cry and cry for you
♪ Maybe tomorrow
00:04:19.040,00:00:00.000
♪ A new romance